[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
let's bring in albert breer the senior
nfl reporter and uh lead content
strategist for the monday morning
quarterback without derrick henry what
kind of team are the tennessee titans
you know like the last two weeks like
you said dan his production hasn't been
what we've gotten used to it being um
and they found different ways to win but
i think you know as well as i do like
part of the fact that they're able to
produce in other areas of the game is
the fact that the defense is game
planning for derek henry and he changes
everything for you so
you know i he's one of the most
important non-quarter x maybe the most
important important non-quarterback to
his team in the nfl
and the drop off from him to jeremy
mcnichols is going to be pretty big so
dear i mean you know you you take him
out of the equation you know i think now
that three-game lead that they took on
the colts um yesterday with that win
looks less insurmountable
and
now jer now is ryan tannehill's gotta go
earn his paycheck right and now this is
you know what it where aj brown's got to
make his money and where the whole julio
jones trade has to come in like it's
just
you know so many things that were built
around derrick henry have been built
around derrick henry the last two plus
years
um you know and and now you sort of have
to reconfigure who you are because i
mean like jeremy jeremy mcnichols is a
nice player but the drop off from henry
to make nichols when you're talking
about a guy you can build your offense
around is massive the saints
quarterbacking situation is interesting
taysom hill was in concussion protocol
trevor simeon comes to the rescue
jameis winston i don't know the severity
of that but i know he was
dancing on crutches after the win but i
don't know if that just hey i'm gonna
have to have surgery here do you know
anything about jameis winston this
morning yet albert yeah i mean i know
that they're bracing for the news that
you know
that confirms the acl tear and that this
is going to be it for the season for him
and it's gonna be interesting seeing
what they do going forward i
i like i was just somebody there told me
last night
just don't assume that it's
automatically going to be taysom hill or
that we're just gonna go straight with
taysom hill as the quarterback when he's
back off the concussion
um and it would the point was raised to
me because you know this guy was talking
to said
we don't really have
like a massive amount of playmakers
versus where they had been in the past
when they had you know i mean brandon
cooks and uh you know mark marcus
colston and and jimmy graham all those
guys over the years they're not in that
spot right now especially with michael
thomas still not playing
and so you know i know there was at
least a thought we'd be better off with
trevor simeon as the quarterback and
then taysom hill in sort of a slash type
of role or a platoon and normally you'd
say like well
you know you don't want to be you know
having a quarter a quarterback shuffle
shuttle will never work in the nfl and
you don't want to be messing with that
because it'll screw with the continuity
of your offense but i mean if there's
one coach who'd be willing to to try it
and who'd be comfortable trying it i
mean it's the one down in new orleans
right
i think it makes the most sense that
just like you said they don't have
weapons they have alvin kamara and if i
can have simeon as the quarterback and
and probably fits a little bit more of
what they're used to with drew brees and
then i can have taysom hill and at least
i can interject him into the offense as
well i and i think with that defense you
know just keep us keep us in the game
you know that's all yeah and uh keep it
close and you know we can help you win
but uh to me that probably makes the
most sense what's the game that you came
away from going what just happened
um
i would say
i mean the saints game i think is it was
interesting but they swept them last
year in the regular season and i think
people underrate the talent on the
saints we get so fixated on the
quarterback you know
um i i don't think people like fully
grasped how good the team around drew
brees was at the end of his career and
how they were sort of carrying him more
than the other way around at the end you
know um
so
now you can't see drew brees coming back
right
i don't think so okay
philip ervers maybe but
like i like i don't think i think you
make your calls if you're sean payton
now you call brees
you call rivers you see what shape those
guys are in because you still feel like
you've got a team capable of winning a
championship i mean this team has been
knocking on the door for five years now
you know brees are no breeze that's
still a roster full of guys who are in
the prime of their career so
i think you know if you're sean payton
you don't just stand pat you turn over
every rock and see
what you might be able to find out there
um phillip river i mean
shoot do you take a swing at deshaun
watson now
well you you will get him because your
cap situation sucks but they've always
been able to solve that you know what i
mean like they've always been able to
find a way
do you take a while because that's the
other thing that that franchise has been
willing to move draft picks in the past
for veteran players they have not been
shy about doing that because they're so
confident in their ability to draft and
develop they don't they feel like they
don't need the surplus of picks that
other teams do so they've been willing
to give up picks in the past
um you know sort of like the rams are
so i mean if you're them do you take a
wild swing at deshaun watson now and i'm
not i'm not suggesting it's going to
happen but i think i think sean will
turn over every rock you know and so
whether it's making a phone call in
watson or
um you know or calling rivers and seeing
hey when your high school season's over
would you want to come out
i like i i just think you have to though
dan that's the thing is because it's to
me it's
like just rattle off the names on that
roster how many guys are right in the
heart of the prime of their careers and
you know your camaras your ryan
ramshacks
i'm your cam jordans is on the back end
you know marshawn lattimore marcus
williams um demario davis like so many
guys that are right there in the heart
of the prime of their careers are on the
back nine
and you know i
i just feel like they've still got an
opportunity to compete at a really high
level and maybe this opens the door for
them to do something creative that they
wouldn't have thought of had james not
gone down we're talking albert brier the
senior nfl reporter lead strategist for
the monday morning quarterback you can
read his column this morning
cooper cup is having one of the greatest
seasons the greatest start to a season
for a wide receiver in over 50 years
why is he not getting any credit
because i think most of the people who
go through that offense don't get credit
it goes to mcvay and whether or not
that's fair or not i'm not you know i
don't know
but
you know like i you know you look at the
skill position players who've gone
through there with the exception of
gurley i think most of those guys have
been seen as sort of a creation of mcday
um
you know robert woods i think the same
way yeah and they clearly value both
those guys both those guys are making 16
17 million dollars a year so it's not
like they don't value them
but i do think there's maybe a little
bit of a perception out there that skill
position players who go through there
are to some degree uh
a production a product of of of the
system and that's why i think people are
so like excited to see what matthew
stafford looks like in it you know
because you had jared goff was another
guy who was seen as the product of the
system the last few years so what
happens if when you put like a true like
franchise type talent in there you know
and we've seen the results so
i think that's really it is that you
know cooper cups never played anywhere
else got tr was wasn't a first round
pick
um you know and and i think part of you
know playing there is so many people
have had success so many skill position
players have had success coming through
that system that now
every guy who does have that sort of
success no matter how much they reward
him or tell you what the money how much
that he means to them and everything
else
like everybody's sort of seen as a cog
in the machine cooper cup is the first
player in the super bowl era with at
least
900 receiving yards 10 touchdowns
through his team's first eight games of
a season pretty pretty good stuff pretty
good
did the jets find their quarterback
yesterday
it's weird isn't it how like
they put him in and josh johnson went
into the middle of that game and he
looked okay too
like so i don't know if it like makes
you raise some questions about zach
wilson and how ready he was to play in
the nfl you know
um
because i think there were some people
that looked at that across the nfl and
said
um is there like like has the staff done
enough with zach wilson you know and you
have a first-time coordinator there and
they went through a tragedy on their
offensive staff over the summer but they
lost the guy who was going to be
like the most experienced guy you know
on that on that staff left on the
offensive side of the ball
um and so i think there were a lot of
people you know inside the league that
were thinking like are they doing enough
to help zach wilson and then you throw
mike white in there and my god he looks
competent you know and this isn't just
this week he looked confident when they
throw him in against the patriots last
week too
so
yeah i mean i think it's fair to ask
some of those questions and i've heard
some of those questions that
like zach has a ways to go as far as
learning just how to run an nfl offense
and how to take house money you know
what i mean like not try to turn every
play into a 70 yard touchdown and i
think you're sort of seeing it now and
maybe it's good for zach wilson to get
to see someone else running the offense
but yeah i mean mike mike white makes i
mean you watch mike white it's like why
did they trade for joe flacco i was sort
of thinking that last week too like like
even after the way he came in and like
stabilized things against the patriots
when they were getting blown out like
you could see a little something there
and i think it definitely carried over
to this week where it's like maybe they
shouldn't have thrown the draft pick
away for joe flacco
uh the cowboys i thought made the right
decision decision even if they had lost
to the vikings that you don't have
you know dak prescott i gotta look for
the bigger picture here what happened
last year and you know you got a team
that can compete in the nfc and you know
cooper rush comes in and
they didn't miss him but you know i
think the bigger question i have is
still about the minnesota vikings albert
because if you have a good quarterback
you're in no man's land you need to have
a great quarterback or it feels like you
start over
you got kirk cousins is a good
quarterback he's not great not elite
um but it feels like they're just that's
a team stuck in neutral yeah if i'm the
i mean i guess the analogy would be if
you're the wilfs right now do you ask
are we the 45-1 nba team right like the
team that's like just good enough to
never get the franchise player
you know that is just sort of stuck
there and you're going out in the first
or second round every year and you're
spinning your wheels
uh and they have like talent in the
roster i actually think like the front
office has done a good job
of kind of replenishing the talent there
and bringing in younger guys you look at
the way they've like
kind of swapped out guys like stefan
diggs is out then you know justin
jefferson comes in in the backfield they
lose adrian peterson he gets older
dalvin cook comes in um the way they've
replaced some guys on the offensive line
darris has played pretty well for them
um you know they've just sort of
constantly been able to
i guess like replenish certain positions
and you wonder is that what's holding
them back is the coaching what's holding
them back because
you know i love mike zimmer as a coach
but they've sort of been in this spot
like they've sort of been the same team
since he got there right like up one
year down the next um that they they
sort of peaked out in 2017 with case
keenum as their quarterback and going to
the nfc title game so yeah i mean i
think if they continue on this path
and you were sitting there at the end of
the season and they're like ten and
seven or nine and eight and they either
just made the playoffs or they're just
out
like i think it's fair to ask those
questions and look like i think
internally they've asked those questions
too
because you know like zimmer was sort of
a sleeper name a couple years ago as a
guy who could wind up out and he
survived and got an extension
and then they kicked the tires really
hard on justin fields in the spring
to the point where
if i mean that was who the bears were
trying to get in front of to get fields
and so maybe they don't trade down and
maybe they wind up with justin fields if
he slips a couple more spots um i think
those questions have been asked
internally
and yeah you wonder if like that doesn't
lead to some change after this year if
things don't change if they don't wind
up like 13 and 4 12 and 5 or whatever
like are you are they just sitting there
spinning their wheels
i'm i i was really surprised at this you
know the browns should have won that
game against the steelers i mean you're
hosting the steelers that you know you
should still win those games but baker
mayfield had this to say
after the game about the media
within sports media world it's going to
be the world's falling down we're going
to handle it within the building and
make the corrections we need to to
execute we have a good enough team it's
just that we're kicking ourselves in the
foot right now stubbing our toes and
just build one week at a time that's why
i said we're going to chip away there's
no big picture mindset we got to chip
away one week at a time and uh we'll do
just that
okay first how do you kick yourself in
the phone i don't know unless it's one
foot kicks the other foot but i think
you shoot yourself on the foot but hey
yeah uh why why does he care about the
media like because he always has
that's part of his rabbit
i mean it's part of it's part of what
it's part of what like drives him right
wasn't this the guy he was in oklahoma
too like he had rabbit ears like
i mean like i don't care they needed my
own water but he like that's what the
flag was right
that's the flag planning was was having
rabbit ears right yeah yeah but yeah i
mean the media part of the browns the
media covers the browns
far more than the browns deserve
yeah i i know what you're saying but
like i don't like
yes you're right because i think there's
like that there's burn there's been that
circus element to it now it's like are
they no longer the circus because i
think kevin stefanski and andrew berry
and those guys did an effective job of
of kind of calming it down
i think it i think there is a fair
question to ask that he's starting to
feel it though like i am now playing for
my job you know because he doesn't have
a contract and generally quarterbacks
who the first round quarterbacks
historically if you look at it the first
round quarterbacks who go through three
years and that then don't get a big
extension
like after that third year just usually
don't get that extension period there i
don't know there's one case where the
team waited and then after year four
andrew luck is the one case which is
where it was like that was just like
wait a year and we'll do it right
but it's very rare that a team
doesn't make that doesn't just give the
guy the extension after the third year
so i'm sure he's feeling it a little bit
too
and that now like a three-in-one start
has become four and four
and if they don't win the playoffs i
mean that's a pretty complete roster
right
so where are they going to look to
upgrade and i think the obvious thing
would be can we afford to have this guy
on our roster at 40 to 45 million
dollars a year that's a very real
question you know
and so like i think baker probably feels
it a little bit feels that pressure a
little bit and he knows that everybody's
looking at him and pointing at him and
saying is he good enough
and um yeah i mean i think it's a fair
question to ask and i think you know if
you gave andrew berry truth serum he
would tell you like right now like for
the rest of this year
it's baker mayfield versus desean watson
it's baker mayfield versus aaron rodgers
it's baker mayfield versus russell
wilson it's baker mayfield versus
whoever might be out there available for
us in february and march when we have to
make a decision on what we want to do
with the position going forward i'll
leave you with this the standalone games
everybody has an opinion the day after
kansas city tonight
how important is to win this game and
win with style points
i i don't think it's you know what's
funny is like people have said that
style points like why doesn't look the
way it used to
i i think like if you talk to enough
people in the league you even talk to
people in that building what they'll
tell you is
they don't need the style points they
need to do the routine stuff better
right like so
they've got this completely reworked
offensive line and that's been a problem
no question orlando brown going right to
left hasn't worked out quite the way
that they hoped it would and when your
left tackle isn't right that can create
problems elsewhere
uh you know but really like how do you
manage that okay well you can manage
that by running the ball effectively
they're not calling enough run plays
like clyde edward solaire is hurt i
understand that but like that's one way
to calm down the offensive line problem
what's another way to calm down the
offensive line problem for mahomes to
take the easy money to to to to check
the ball down to throw the ball short so
he's not holding it as long so it
doesn't expose the issue he's not doing
that
you know is mahomes playing too much
like he did at texas tech like are we
seeing that guy who felt like he had to
take the team on his shoulders too much
and he's not doing that he's not doing
the routine thing and then on defense
it's the two guys that you paid it's
frank clark and it's and it's and it's
chris jones like are those guys coming
anywhere close to what they're getting
paid they've been banged up they've been
averaged when they've been out there and
not having those guys play at the level
that they've played at the last couple
of years has exposed an ordinary back
seven so i think a lot of this stuff is
pretty simple it's on offense can they
make the routine play right like can
they make the routine play can they go
to people other than travis kelsey or
tyree kill
and can mahomes play like a more
conservative game
and then defensively i mean the offense
playing more conservatively would help
the defense right like because now
you're maybe shortening the game a
little bit which isn't their comfort
zone but maybe what you have to do here
can you get your best players on defense
playing better to me it's like it's it's
like two three four if you talk to
people in that building it's like two
three four very simple things
but you can't say with any certainty
that it's just gonna click and happen
great to talk to you as always thank you
bud all right thanks for having me dan
that's albert breer the monday morning
quarterback why do i feel like the
giants are gonna lead tonight three to
nothing